[Music]
[Applause]
Bob Ryan long time Boston Globe sports
columnist and a contributor to Around
the Horn joins us on the program Bob
thanks for joining us on short notice
what do you make of these new NBA awards
well I guess it's all about the the
Bucks and somebody's going to sponsor
them and that's fine but it'll be you're
not going to please you know this thing
you never you can't please them all you
can't please people you can't get a
unanimity of opinion about who's
deserving these Awards I am with you on
the Kareem versus Michael thing no
slight to Michael but when are they
going to get around to taking uh paying
homage to Kareem properly I think yeah
um so that would be good but that's you
know uh I I have a nominee for the
defensive award that you know people
that quite frankly uh is a better
technical nominee than than a kakim
Elijah one but I can understand why it
would be a little bit of a hesitancy to
name an award after Dennis Rodman
um so uh you know who frankly is
arguably uh the best all-around Defender
if the game has ever known and that he'd
be able to guard anybody from point
guards to centers and and all that this
has been a few people like that but he's
the best of them all I think um but he's
Dennis Rodman that's he's a you know
a character to say the least well that's
interesting I heard somebody yesterday
uh on there complaining uh about
um the Havoc uh name on the six-man
award uh and that one of course you know
I'll fight that one to the death I'll
fight that one by the way when John
passed a couple years ago
um he was you know always known as the
great Sixth Man and I said it was
damning him with faint praise because
even as early as his second year in the
league though he was in fact not
starting games he was second on that
team in minutes played behind Bill
Russell and that was that that remained
the case for the told time he was a
sixth man anyway it's it it's you know
what we're talking about it I think
that's that's probably something they
like too yeah I I agree with that and
some of these names like George Mike and
okay people maybe they'll do some
homework there with George Michael but
most improved he came in averaging you
know 27 and 15 or something like that he
never had no absolutely no that that's
that's preposterous
I'd have to think now that this has been
can you bring this up I'll have to do
some thinking who would be a an
appropriate person to name that award
after who who went the farthest you know
from from obscurity to stardom uh I'll
get back to you on that one but I don't
have it on the top of my head I was
thinking degree wasn't George Michael
The Greek Freak Bob but he's still
playing
yeah like okay right he did uh with the
averages of rookie yeah that's true
um so but there's the obviously Mike in
this it's just a name it's nice to have
George Michael remembered and uh you
know uh he could uh the best uh
nearsighted player of all time that
would be good you know
you know that people you know he played
with glasses yeah it was a pre-contact
contact lens world that he lived in so
anyway why don't we honor Kareem though
Bob I I know he missed out on social
media he was not lovable he's the
greatest college player of all time he
made it look maybe too easy but you know
it just feels I I uh I you know I I
don't know and his post career he has
you know become a distinguished you know
we know he's an intellect he's an author
he's he's he's he's taken up causes of
uh Native American causes uh for example
uh he's a person he's a go-to person on
us on any social commentary that of the
time uh and you know he's if you're
going to start going in terms of uh
all-time IQs in the league he's going to
be in in the high high high in the list
uh and he he never did anything to
disgrace the game he never did he was
never in uh in the news in the long part
of the newspaper that I know of uh and
uh you know um I I he he was and he he
has the greatest signature shot in the
history of basketball the most famous
weapon ever singular weapon is this hope
shot yeah
what do you think LeBron's reaction was
when he learned that the MVP trophy was
going to be named after Michael Jordan
obviously doesn't
it and and then you know he has a right
to to stick up them so I'm sure he was
saying hey wait a minute wait I'm I'm
well I'm done but he's not going to
catch Michael in total the MVPs we know
that you're not going to do it so if
that's the card the you know the
criteria he's he he loses but he is you
know I I count me among those who when
we're talking about the two greatest
individual all-around talents in the
history of the game uh and and as
opposed to centers which is a whole
other discussion
um it's it's Michael LeBron and and I
can make a case for either one
yeah I'm just curious because there is
that debater there's always been that
debate and if you're LeBron you're like
wait a minute my career is not over I'm
going to be the all-time leading scorer
I'm going to be up there and assist I'm
going to be up there with All-Stars
longevity you know all of those things
in totality LeBron is going to have a
better career than Michael Jordan except
that you and I all right those of us who
were around for Michael and and have
seen LeBron uh let me tell you this too
here's the difference in the two and how
they got to the the Pinnacle and in
their respective Iris Michael ascended
to the NBA Mountaintop when he finally
learned how to share and and he was that
the 1987 Michael wasn't making that pass
to Steve Carr he wasn't making that pass
to John Paxson the 1991 Michael would do
those things and that that got him ring
so he he could have had Rings earlier I
I will argue that LeBron didn't Ascend
to the Mountaintop until he recognized
that that the responsibility of being
the best player in the floor and acting
accordingly he bombed out against the
Fabrics he did not want the ball I
resisted that but it's true I saw him
quit against the Celtics in 2010
um and and so what I'm getting that if
you're in the Foxhole the guy you want
is Michael Michael is the greatest
competitor and the closest thing to him
1A to him is Kobe and and LeBron does
not enter into that discussion the way
with those other two sorry LeBron that's
the fact
I've been watching The Shack documentary
and I I remember at the time when when
they broke up that we would remember
what they could have been not what they
did you know it's the three Pete is one
thing
I mean it's really I look back on what
could have been not what was what do you
what do you take away from them well at
the time at
the decided you know when it was going
on and it was this the triangle was was
was you know Kobe uh Lebron and uh and
uh no excuse me it's Kobe Shack and Phil
that was that was the actual triangle
that mattered at that point not not Tex
Ritter's offense uh and I sided with
with uh Shaq and in that regard and um
at that time uh we'll we'll never know
obviously they should have stayed
together they would have but they're not
the only circumstance of that nature we
could cite uh in in any sport but that
certainly is one that that was true my
only has my only yeah but on LeBron I'm
excited to be on Shaq and and ranking
him in the pier in hierarchy of all the
all-time players is simply he should
have been a better rebounder I think
it's Preposterous that that man did not
leave the league of rebounds even once
and and rebounding is the number one
rule of rebounding is you want the damn
baller don't you and you start with that
and he was a somewhat indifferent
rebounder for far too long in his career
yeah that's interesting but why did the
Celtics work when you had bird Michael
and Parish and DJ and Ainge that did
jealousy it was jealousy ever part of
the equation there
no I know I mean the thing is that the
Lakers were concurrently great at the
same time then the Lakers had the upper
hand they went two out of three times
they played in the 80s uh against them
fair and square
um so you know the Celtics accomplished
uh what what they should have I think
with that group I may be uh you know uh
just just no excuses for for 85 uh uh
there's uh there is a yeah about an 87
they were battered Mikhail was playing
with the bed foot and and then they
would their bench was stripped and they
were nowhere near as good as the Lakers
that they took them the six was a was a
miracle so uh that was that but uh no I
don't know where you know no the Celtics
that group no they were they were mutual
admiration there were to my knowledge
there was no friction of any substance
of any kind with that group I enjoyed
watching the 20th anniversary Around the
Horn last night Bob I know you were
there for uh the made-up Voyage day one
yeah who who would have thought 20 years
later well you know TV I mean it's a
remarkable and but what what this what's
interesting about this whole scenario is
that you can't discuss Around the Horn
without discussing PTI Around the Horn
is a spin-off it is the most successful
spin-off probably in American TV sports
history and and Baba the only one that
that has really you know PTI came on the
air in November of 01. I remember in
January of 02 watching a game on TV at
from University of Arkansas and someone
was holding up one of those face figures
you know of either Tony or Mike in the
stands yeah and I was thinking oh my God
something's going on out there you know
this is interesting and it turned out
the college audiences were a real staple
audience have been all the time for both
shows but
um that show caught on and only because
it caught on uh that was their agitation
or in business there to to try and build
off it and and you know as you know they
are the the genius the one name that
didn't get mentioned I I don't believe
last night it was The Guiding genius
behind both shows and that's Eric
Whiteholm who created all the games and
all the formats in both shows and and
without host genius the shows wouldn't
be what they are but ultimately we owe
our existence on around the horn to the
personalities of Tony and Mike who who
made that show of how popular and and
and made it possible for us to have a
show and we we so it starts with them
and then secondly uh with Tony reali has
done as a host that it's the hardest
hosting job I think in the history of TV
think about it you've got the normal
hosting duties of banter and having the
the producer and the director in your
ear which allow these people at home
never think about then you've got the
listen to these commentaries uh these
things you're playing off it you're ad
living and you're keeping score with
these these levers all at once that's
juggling a lot and he makes it seem like
it's the easiest snap job in the world
and you know it is not and all hosting
jobs I had total respect for it but uh
that one above all and and Tony has been
you know just grown up in our eyes as he
pointed out last night he was 25 when it
started and you know he was not
intending to be a personality he was a
researcher he was going to be a behind
the scenes guy and and he towed up on
PTI at the 11th Hour as as the uh
information guide or the guy and then he
became transitioned into the show and
here we are 20 years later who would
have thought yeah
great to talk to you Bob thanks uh for
joining us we appreciate it oh it's
great to be with you thank you that's
right that's Bob Ryan long time Boston
Globe sports columnist